[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de base on vient voir adrien catena ce
que l'on suit depuis le métier ou de
mélenchon et avec mon pote victor on on
à ses fans de lui et on veut voir sa
musique et du coup on assez intrigué
aussi pour liberté l'ex tiphaine que
j'ai jamais vu en concert l'adversaire
principal c'est la résignation d'abord
parce que moi je pense que la république
en marche
là dans la période ils nous donnent
l'impression d'être aux abonnés absents
c'est à dire qu'on a le sentiment d'un
président d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un
sentiment c'est un président de la
république qui en quelque sorte vous les
enjamber ces élections législatives
qu'on ne parle surtout de rien on serre
les dents on se cramponne on attend que
ça passe et on aura une majorité
la réalité c'est que c'est autre chose
qui est en train de se passer il le voit
est donc depuis dix jours c'est feu
roulant contre jean luc mélenchon et ses
partenaires bon moi je crois que c'est
un bon sondage nous avons créé
régulièrement les conditions pour nous
rendre utiles tout de suite poyer des
professions de choix même plus capable
d'organiser des élections